OK, I'm Jad Abumrad. This is more perfect.
In United States,
we keep the supreme court the power to find justice for people come with boats.
People who've been abused and manipulated, oh, sure. Bought it. I mean they,
they knock on their door. That power extends beyond state borders.
He can with [inaudible] sometimes even beyond national borders with common show
you who your Yam question is, how far do we want it to go?
Should our supreme court be the Supreme Court of the world?
The honorable,
the chief justice and the justices of the Supreme Court of the United States.
Oh, Yay. Yay.
Having business before the honorable,
the Supreme Court of the United States are admonished to draw near and give
their intent.
[inaudible]
yeah,
yeah.
[inaudible]
okay,
so I grew up at a time when a lot of people genuinely saw America differently
than they do now. This is the 70s and eighties Carter Reagan years.
And there was this sense particularly for you or new arrival that America was
special, exceptional, that we held the world to a higher standard.
Certainly what brought my family to America. Okay. So it's not that way anymore.
So much, and it seems like every day, at least in my lifetime,
we're asking the question, how should we feel about that?
Whatever that is, that higher calling,
that somehow for better or worse embedded in the idea of being an American,
is that stupidly wrong-headed and arrogant or is there something in that that we
still should embrace?
[inaudible]
turns out that argument is happening,
has been happening in a totally fascinating way at the supreme court,
centered around this teeny, teeny little,
whoa.
It seems to ask some pretty big questions about who we are.
We want to be story comes from two KPS Kelsey paget high and Kelly prime KP two
k p one I believe you are now KPV one. Okay. You have ascended the ranks.
I am now KP two or three year old [inaudible] seven stop.
It can't be 12. Okay, so Kelly start us off. Yeah. So,
uh, this story begins appropriately enough. Not In America,
but it starts in 1976 with a this woman I have to get used to.
Yeah. Okay. So I guess the first thing,
if you could just introduce yourself. My name is [inaudible].
I am from [inaudible]. Why
[inaudible]
Paraguay. It's a small country, right on top of Argentina and Dolly's family.
The Florida NGOs
are a pretty big deal over there.
What happened in my family was that my grandfather was very rich.
The Florida has made their money exporting tobacco to Europe for big cigarette
companies like them. Cause you Tom [inaudible],
a family that owns a beautiful house in the country side,
lots of land do airplane.
Now this could have been Dolly's life,
but it will say Sam going to be like that and it wasn't because of her father.
I'm your father. What's his name or what? Boyd Coil. And what,
what did your dad do for a living? He said though,
Darn her dad very famously turned his back on his fancy upbringing and moved the
entire family to the countryside.
The old world was short on money and there he set up a clinic to give medical
care to the poor indigenous farmers in that area. He,
they get off lay 47,000 people.
He was the only doctor in a lot of cities.
Her Dad became kind of like a patron saint of the countryside.
Not only would he give the medical treatment, but when they came in,
he would tell them, go vote,
rise above your station and as you can imagine as word got out,
this really pissed off Paraguay's ruler at the time,
a guy named Alfredo strossner's,
he was called the [inaudible],
the octopus because he said he had arms and tentacles that reach into
everybody's lives there in the country. That's her name, Horst.
I'm a professor of Latin American history here at Appalachian State University.
When Dolly was growing up, Rooney live next door and for Mosa, Argentina,
right across the river from Paraguay and Renee says at that time,
both Argentina and Paraguay were part of this like big network of dictators all
across Latin America and it was called Operation Condor.
Operation Condor was a network that linked together military dictatorships of
Latin America, so Brazil, Argentina, Chile,
Bolivia, Oregon, Paraguay,
and it was all masterminded by Pinochet in Chile.
Renee said the operation condor was a lot like a spider web with Pinochet as the
master weaver, the spider,
the communist revolution in Cuba had just happened.
And so these six super militaristic dictatorships,
they banded together to pretty much trap communism and keep it out of South
America. Remember,
this was the Cold War and America really wanted to keep communism out of the
continent too.
So it's really likely that the CIA was involved and the result was a network of
state sponsored terror.
In the darkest part of the night,
they would come to your apartment and drag you out and stuff.
You're in the trunk of a Ford Falcon car and you would disappear forever.
My father used to tell the Pesa,
don't vote for a restaurant.
No. So this was these. The context behind Dr Florida goes rebellion.
Dolly said he travel all over the world, giving talks,
trying to show everything what astronomer was doing in the country.
[inaudible] tells patients when the government comes to buy your crops,
put it away. Don't sell it, don't give them a thing.
[inaudible]
Dolly tried her best to ignore all this. We didn't get that loan with my father.
I have to say that.
So when I get all there,
she moved away from the country and I can't do the CT to leave.
What city was it? As soon as she worked to put herself through school and then
[inaudible] follow me after and then Dolly says she worked upon her two siblings
through school.
Her sister Ali at the time was 14 and her brother Halito was 17 love Carlito
love Corleto. He was her favorite.
Carlito looked named my mother green eyes cause Daniel hair light hair.
I know that he had
a lot of girls that crust on him. This is Dolly's daughter. Paloma.
Very handsome. Yes. But he wasn't a player. Anything in what was,
what was halitosis personality like? Was He loud? Was He quiet?
You see those people that say things and you laugh. Fico,
he's so funny all the time. Just people that they jogged comedian,
comedian, we always saw that he would become a call me Yak. He was very funny.
So, so you two were close. Very close. So that's the backdrop.
1970 $6 in the city with their two siblings or her dad's out in the country
jumping up opposition to the regime at that time who I lead,
he tells many friends that he felt like he was being fallow.
He didn't want to tell us because we always tell him to be careful.
Even my father coil used to tell him,
be careful because you are who I my son. And he was
and at that time in Paraguay,
it was well known that there were spies everywhere.
The put away put away is an expression in what I nee person with hairy feet with
hair is call it Peter way, it's a nickname for informers of the regime.
So things were already tense.
And then on March 29th,
1976 Dolly and her siblings are turning in for the night.
Around 11 maybe Dolly and Emily both sleep in one bed.
Carlito has his room. And so he went to his teeth.
And then when I go night
and what happened was
we've, we here in the middle of the night,
maybe three o clock was
the bomb being in that door.
[inaudible] and she wakes up like what's happening.
She throws on a coat over her nightgown to cover myself and she goes to the door
where she finds a cop. He say, you'll have to come with me.
That is a little problem.
Was your brother as bang your house at Penny's house?
Remember that name is [inaudible]. I mainly got Pena.
He lived two doors down and she didn't know him too well,
but he was a policemen and she'd always had suspicions about him.
So Dolly steps out into the chilly night in her nightgown.
This street was for all police man car.
The officer who was at the door walked her over to Pena's house into the house
down a long hallway that she says was lined with even more policemen.
They may be Walsh,
I don't know,
70 and then 35 and 35 one close to another.
She says she walked down the hall, the policemen sort of parted for her
[inaudible]
and guided her to a room in the back of the house. A went into that room,
open that door. And so Harley,
he was lying on his back on a mattress and this
gorgeous human being. My brother was so beautiful.
His body is covered in gashes.
You can see where he's been stabbed over and over again and maybe tied up.
They were here. They cut him. I found the, the, the, the,
these out. These, there was an electrical wire attached to his genitals.
Most drawshop. Terrible, terrible.
[inaudible]. I don't know how to spray. How, how other human being can do,
can do that to another one who never did anything to you to, to,
to, I don't know.
Dolly says she bolted out of the room and immediately ran into Inspector General
Pena.
He was standing in the doorway. I saw Pena in my wife. Pena told me,
[inaudible] you better shut up.
He is the thing that you the surf and you better get quiet because nick mu will
be used something. Lands.
He told you next time it would be you.
Yeah. In your farm. Maybe. You bet there. Shut up. I say I am.
Don't you feel that? You don't know why? I know.
Don't you feel that? [inaudible] you made me shut up today,
but tomorrow I will valley. We'll know what you did to my brother.
[inaudible]
over the next three years, the family tried to get justice.
They sued Pena in the Paraguayan courts, but their lawyers were threatened.
One was disbarred when Dolly and her mom testified against Pena [inaudible] so
we went through jet when Dolly and her mom got out of jail,
they raised publicity and was showing what they did to my brother.
They convinced reporters to write newspaper articles to call for an
investigation. But before anything could happen,
Pena, he disappear. He vanished. He fled the country altogether.
So the question is, if you're Dolly, what do you do?
Your brother has just been brutally murdered. You know who did it? But you know,
you can't get just as in Paraguay because the whole court systems in with the
regime and you can't go to the international criminal court because it doesn't
exist yet. And even if it did exist, your case is way too small.
So what do you do when I say we have to do something?
Fast forward to 1979 I moved to Washington,
Dolly's living in D C cleaning, cooking, cleaning houses,
working part time at a law firm.
All this time she's had feelers out with her dad's connections at NGOs.
Just trying to find out at least where Pena is living.
I only have communication with [inaudible]. Finally,
one day that spring,
she got a phone call from one of those connections they found Benya they told me
that Pena was leaving Katie in Brooklyn.
He'd been working at a furniture store in Brooklyn when a fellow Paraguayan had
recognized him out at him. Ivy know what I was going to do,
but they wanted justice.
[inaudible]
how do you get justice in this case?
I with this [inaudible] you got a pair of Gwen responsible for the death of
another Paraguayan in Paraguay.
Both people are to the scenes that'll happen in fire wise,
like even if he did something wrong, don't why? Which it seems like he did.
There's not like this has nothing to do with America. Not Seen
[inaudible]
what'd I say? We have to do something. So I was looking for help.
Deli contacts. A lawyer who gets her in touch with this guy, Dan Peter, wise,
wise, Jennifer Constitution Center for constitutional rights.
Peter says even before Dali showed up,
we were trying to figure out how to sue people committing crimes against
humanity and war crimes. For example,
504 on armed Vietnamese women,
children and old men were massacred over a four hour period by US troops.
This was around the time of the me lie mask in central Vietnam when that
happened by colleagues at the center and I had been wondering was there a way
for them to bring a case against the u s military on behalf of one of the
victims in an American Colette if the crime was committed abroad.
So I came and met Peter and asked for help.
So I called an emergency meeting of the center staff and he asked them like,
is there a way we can help?
Is there some like wormhole in American law that would let us bring non
Americans and crimes
into American courts?
One of us at the center was obviously a good researcher
and they said, hey, you know, there's this super old super obscure law,
something called the Alien Tort Statute.
The what? The Alien Tort Statute.
And it seemed a just right for that case.
I don't know how many hours and hours and hours and hours they tried to find
Nally. They found these low that they used to use against the
[inaudible] [inaudible] pirates. Vida. Thank you. Pirates. Yeah.
Would a pirates have to do with anything? Oh, who yet? What? What?
Are you straight to me or do you want to go kill?
It's a handoff to someone answering my questions. Sure. By the way,
I'm Chelsea pageant a reporter and yes, this story has to do with pirates.
Definitely. We'll get there before that.
There's this even crazier background. Okay. You gotta you gotta buy it.
You gotta go with me on this journey because you know, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's a lot different. [inaudible] the rest of the story.
So ready to go on this journey. Take my hand.
We'll go into a little a belt
all the way back in 1784 granola and a banana.
This is William Casto, he's a law professor at Texas Tech.
He told me this story and it's really a story of like, like,
yeah, here's the situation.
It's 1784 you've got this guy, Mr Delong Champs,
Charles Julian Delong chumps and he's a French guy and he's living in Philly.
He was,
apparently it was an officer in a French cavalry regiment and a nobleman by
birth, by the way. Some people didn't like him.
Thomas Jefferson said he's an obs quote,
obscure and worthless character. Okay. Why? Why do you say that?
It doesn't matter. What's important is that he is here in America,
has a bad reputation and he ends up meeting this guy, girl,
a nice young Quaker girl,
a quote Eris to a competent fortune. Oh yeah.
And her friends disapproved very much so and so they started circulating rumors
around town around Philadelphia that long. John was a liar,
that he was not of noble birth and wasn't even an officer and he was just
probably gold digging, you know, since she had this money,
delong shops is really mad about this.
He was incensed and he put on his uniform that he stormed over to the French
embassy. He goes to the embassy.
Larry spoke with Francoise, Barb Mar Bois,
another French guy who was the embassy's first secretary.
And here's an aside. Yeah.
Marwan later was Napoleon's minister of finance. Oh,
and he negotiated the Louisiana purchase.
But that's just an aside point is mar Bois is like unimportant dude.
But you know the other French guy, delong chomps, the maybe scoundrel guy,
he walks in and he's like, I guess he doesn't show a lot of respect. He's like,
you know, I need you to drop everything and help me out with this situation.
Cause people are spreading rumors about me.
They're saying I'm not a noblemen or whatever. I need you to stand up for me.
And Martin Bois refused. We don't know why. At any rate,
in response long, chomp shouted at Marwan I'll translate it.
I will dishonor you. And then he called him,
and this is a translation, a laughable scam,
which is kind of,
can you imagine people calling someone a laughable scam today?
It seems tame, honestly, Very Tang.
But those words would create a national crisis.
[inaudible]
the fact everything we're talking about today goes back to this little
confrontation.
How white sibling honor was this big deal back in the tape.
Like it's why Hamilton dies, right?
Something like calling someone a laughable scamp Ooh. Could cause a death.
You know what I mean? Like that's the kind of thing you do a duel over.
It was an indignity. Marvel.
I was so pissed at the moment and he did the right thing in that time period,
which is instead of having a dual with the man, he contacted his bosses,
he wrote a letter, you know, across the scenes to France and said, y'all,
what are we gonna do about this? Now the French don't like what's going on.
The French want us to put him on a ship back to France and have France punish
their long champs. And the, uh,
Pennsylvania executive council agreed,
but the judges refuse. They say, we're not gonna do that. That's ridiculous.
All that causes France to say, you know what,
if we can't be sure that America is going to take care of this,
that they're going to punish this guy.
Maybe we can't take this brand new country. Seriously.
Maybe it's a land of no law. Uh, so it really escalate.
Yeah. Becomes this huge thing. And you got to keep in mind, at that time,
United States was a third world nation. We were weak.
France had been our buddy during the revolution and the feeling was we
desperately needed the help of other countries because we were just this baby
little country. By the way, the Dutch ambassador was furious too,
because he said, if you don't punish long jobs,
I'm leaving the state. He actually threatened to leave the state.
It really created problems. So we had to do something.
But the question was what the national government had no authority whatsoever to
deal with or punish it, a personal,
lifelong jobs because it wasn't a crime to just say, I will dishonor you.
And even if it were,
the insult happened at what was essentially the French embassy.
Some have argued that that made it this a situation outside of the United
States. Oh, so I step in there and I'm a suddenly under the rules of friends.
Yeah, yeah. That's the argument. You know,
did we have jurisdiction over that space?
Did we not point is that the new US government, they were just powerless.
They didn't know what to do. What happened? Well, so the case goes to court.
The judge, in that case he's trying to figure out what to do.
He's in a really bad political situation.
He's got to punish this guy and he's looking at his books, no law,
he's got no laws to charge this guy vendor. And then it occurs to him. You know,
there are some other laws that aren't explicitly written down,
but that all people across the world agree are bad things.
All nations agree that this is bad and can be punished.
And the classic example of that is pirates.
Pirates are out there on the open seas, are pillaging, pondering, killing,
and they are not really subject to any one nation's laws.
They're not doing this in a nation.
No one had specific jurisdiction over them and going all the way back to Roman
times, pirates were designated as universal enemies.
The hostess who money generous,
that same l Moines history professor at Yale University,
the phrase in Latin is hostess who? Moni generous,
which means the enemy of the human kind or race.
And it means that maybe there's things that are so heinous.
Um,
you don't have to pass a law to make them illegal and you don't have to be
empowered to,
to stop or punish the perpetrator of such crimes because they're just so bad.
And piracy was the classic example.
Okay.
So what the judge decides is that this French guy in Philadelphia who insults
the fancy French guy in Philadelphia,
the way that we're going to solve this is by saying that the insulator,
he's a little bit like a pirate. No, he doesn't use the term pirates,
but it's the same concept. He said that that guy,
delong Trump has broken international norms.
He is guilty of an atrocious violation of the law of nations.
He not only fronts the sovereign he represents,
but also hurts the common safety and wellbeing of nations.
He is guilty of a crime against the whole world and that's a quote from the
ruling.
They then find him a hundred French crowns and two years in jail,
two years, two years per same odd for bays. I will dishonor you.
Wow. Okay. This move by the judge, it basically works.
I'm Mar Bois and fence feel good. Their honor's been protected.
The Dutch ambassador doesn't leave. He stays.
But more importantly for our story,
in 1789 congress passes some of their very first laws.
There's like this one big bill about courts and in there is this thing called
the alien tort statute,
the Alien Tort Statute. You know,
it was written into law to deal with this kind of situation where a diplomat is
insulted or attacked or something like that,
but more generally it was meant to connect us law to international law.
The law basically says, and I'm simplifying this a bunch,
but it basically says like if somebody violates international norms, you know,
like a crime against the whole world, they can be sued in u s civil courts.
Wait,
you're saying there was a law from the beginning that allows a non u s people to
sue each other for non u s crimes in u s courts? Yeah.
It's so weird. But, but like the thing is this is, this is Kelly again.
Hello Kelly. When it comes to this law, like forever, no one actually used it.
It was barely mentioned for 200 years. Why?
Why wouldn't it come up if you think about it though? It kind of makes sense.
It wasn't used because it was a super specific law.
Like this was a weird circumstance in which we really needed to bring
international law and use it inside our borders. But that kind of thing,
like diplomatic fights, like that didn't happen very often. Yeah.
And more generally the prevailing idea at the time was that internationally we
should kind of stay in our lane. Like,
if you're gonna come into our country and mess with our citizens, like, yeah,
we're going to do something about that.
But if you want to do something to your own citizens,
that's not my business.
There's an old idea that in every country the government can do to its people,
whatever it wants. And nobody in any foreign country,
no foreign government has any business telling them what to do.
This is Eric Posner,
professor of law at the University of Chicago.
And he says,
the reason that the alien tort statute was pretty much ignored is because of
this idea,
this idea of sovereignty
that we're not going to tell you what to do in your borders.
So don't you come into our country and tell us what to do.
Most people don't know this,
but there was actually a humanitarian basis for this harsh sounding principle
came about in the 17th century. He says,
the problem back in the 17th century were a religious wars.
Protestants invade the Catholics, Catholics invade the Protestants,
you know, endless strife. And so the idea was, um,
let's simplify things and just understand that in foreign countries people have
different values and ideas and it's just not practical or good in the long run.
If we try to tell people in foreign countries how they should behave,
and this was the dominant view for hundreds of years
until World War II really, but
the Holocaust changed everything. No words can express the world.
At Germany's organized Carney,
one of the defenses that Nazis gave to the specific charge of massacring Jews is
that they're protected by the principle of sovereignty. That was, uh, you know,
considered an unacceptable argument.
And countries around the world basically agreed that limits had to be put on
sovereignty and those limits would be known as human rights.
And just a few years later, in 1948,
you get the Universal Declaration of Human Rights
on which the organized can be a little nice, my,
the declaration of him and rights.
And suddenly all eyes turn to human rights. It's a golden moment.
Professor Samuel Mine again, he says, if you fast forward to the seventies
Americans having fought Vietnam,
having solid themselves and doing so want to bring human rights to the world
and the human rights movement was very exciting. You know,
there were rock concerts and gentlemen, a lot of famous people, you know, it's
Joan Baez and a lot of, you know,
rock stars and pop culture icons get involved.
[inaudible] the notion international amnesty wins the peace prize peace prize
for 1972. So, um,
as long as I am prejudiced Jimmy Carter's and fighting the government of the
United States dissidents from eastern Europe to visit the White House and you
throughout the world to enhance human rights, it's a lit,
it's a new cause that's very exciting to a lot of people and rightly so.
It would be great if America could make the world a better place.
[inaudible]
so this brings us back to Dali.
So I came and met Peter in Peter Weiss for constitutional rights,
trying to figure out how to bring dallies case to u s courts.
That's the context. America is having this moment with human rights.
And we want to bring it to the rest of the world.
So when someone in Peter's office suggest using this old little law to get
justice for Dolly, it seems obvious like of course.
So I called an emergency meeting of the center staff.
Basically their idea was that some crimes like piracy were so bad that the
borders didn't matter. Like anyone should be able to prosecute them.
And the U s should be able to bring these people to court on behalf of the
world.
Would I?
I have to tell you that the majority of you are calling status on where you were
slightly insane. Did your boss say like what? Yeah.
People said you're never gonna get anywhere with this.
It's all about Paraguard.
So Dolly's lawyers,
they filed their papers and eventually this case gets in front of a federal
circuit court.
So the federal court, Eastern District [inaudible] Glenn,
in the day of the trial, you saw Pena in the elevator
at court.
Yes, I met [inaudible] and I asked him,
why do you do that to my brother? Why did you do that to him?
Why he couldn't answer? He was shaking
anyway. We were in the car. He [inaudible]
what in the court. They submitted autopsy reports. We ran their photographer
for, for for Tog rougher pictures. We,
we bring a picture of him with the mattress or Lita was in the mattress time,
their feet and the hands. Ladies.
And Peter says that after he made his argument, an interesting thing happened.
When I finished my argument,
the judge started to go back to his chambers and before he got out of the code
from, he turned around and said,
interesting case.
Hm. Ooh. So what happened? Well, the judge ruled against them.
Ah, but they appeal.
It goes up to the second circuit
and ultimately a judge orders Pena to pay $10 million to Dolly and her family,
they won. Yeah.
What happened
was like a miracle.
I was able to get justice in United States in the Florida case.
They convinced the second circuit that the alien tort statute,
it wasn't just for stuffy diplomats anymore, was for human rights period.
They say, look,
torture isn't now like piracy and this ruling sets off and then we're off to the
races.
An explosion of cases.
I mean in 1984 you had Taliban v,
Libyan Arab Republic and east I believe, or 85 the Soviet Union, Ben Dardo,
the USSR. In 87 there was a case from Argentina called 40 v Suarez Mason.
He Swan, therefore 1991 Guatemala, 1993, Ecuador and Peru,
95 former Yugoslavia in 1999. Sheila [inaudible].
Basically what you saw in the eighties and nineties and into the early two
thousands is that cases from all over the world started just like flooding into
American court.
The reason this statute is so important is that it, it's American law.
It gives American lawyers who want to use their legal training,
something to do as part of this because lawyers can save the world while
practicing law.
Since looking at the role of the TS, um,
it's hard to underestimate just how much impact it's had.
This is Katherine Gallagher also from the Center for constitutional rights.
The [inaudible]
statute over the last 35 years has become the source of almost all six,
the African human rights litigation in the United States and indeed in the
world.
And that's John Bellinger legal advisor for the Department of state from 2005 to
2009 before filler Dukkha,
there was very little that victims of human rights violations could do.
There were a lot of folks,
especially in the American legal system who felt like America had never been a
greater force for good in the world.
[inaudible]
but the rest of the world wasn't so sure.
that's coming up. Yeah. Perfect. We'll continue in a moment.
[inaudible]
cut
a new podcast about juvenile justice from w NYC studios follows a group of kids
as they navigate their way through our criminal justice system.
These aren't stories about innocence. They ask once the kid is caught,
what happens next?
I don't want to even wish like jail on nobody like cause there's not a nice
place to be because if you do something or say something wrong and you're going
to get in more trouble or like down on copyright, the host of caught,
listen and subscribe to caught [inaudible]
wherever you get your podcasts,
this is more perfect. I'm jet out. Boom. Run back to the two KPS,
Kelsey paget and Kelly prime. Here's Kelly, where we left it.
Florida just happened. We had an explosion of cases.
American human rights lawyers were feeling really good about themselves.
But diplomacy is a delicate thing.
Many foreign governments, uh,
including many Western democracies. That's John Ballenger again,
Great Britain, Australia, Germany,
Switzerland would regularly complain to me as the legal advisor of the State
Department that they thought that the alien tort statute was in fact itself a
violation of international law because it allowed us judges to have jurisdiction
over actions that had absolutely nothing to do with the United States.
But instead of dialing it back, human rights lawyers,
they decided why not push it even further?
[inaudible]
so around 1995, they made a big leap.
They decided that instead of just going after individuals like foreign
government officials,
they were going to use this law to go after foreign corporations.
When the first alien tort statute cases were filed against corporations,
these cases were really seen as, um,
slightly crazy. How can you do this? These are corporations.
These are not governments. These are not dictators.
How can you see them under this law?
But what human rights lawyers said was [inaudible] Dolly's case showed us that
this law is about modern day pirates.
What better example of pirates do we have nowadays than multinational
corporations? If you want to go all the way,
you could say do these big massive entities that just can reach out their
tentacles into any country and they float between jurisdictions,
move from one to the next to the next and come a brutal crimes.
Like sometimes they empower dictators to commit those crimes and when you try
and pin them down, like when you want to hold them accountable,
they can just vanish.
So yeah, all of that sounds, you know, really abstract.
For me, it didn't really register like why you would go after a corporation.
Until I heard this story, the story of Ken, Sarah Wheela.
I mean I grew up in a political household that my father was a,
was a national figure because he was a writer and a commentator in newspapers.
Just like Dolly. Ken had this famously outspoken dad, very much a social critic.
He was a famous thorn in the side of the regime.
The regime in this case is this military dictatorship in Nigeria.
You Use eve?
The military depends on the civilian democratically elected president sugary in
the eighties and nineties Nigeria went through a series of military coups and
Ken's dad who actually wrote a sitcom that was like very famous,
millions of people around the country watched it.
He would make jokes about the regimes.
He would write articles about them and you know the subject of his birth,
his columns and his and his television program,
the inequalities of Nigeria's political system.
The situation at the time in Nigeria was that you had tons of oil under the
ground [inaudible] estimated $30 billion worth of oil and in order for the
military regime to get that out, they partnered with a division of shell
shell companies in my jewelry, right.
I'll supplying domestic gas and generating electricity from was
the people who lived on the land where the oil was,
they're really poor and they weren't given barely any of this money
against that.
To add insult to injury on Chet oil production or was creating an environmental
disaster in our community.
What we're working on now is crude oil and this land is lost or the next
thousand years,
this is a clip of kin's father showing a reporter ruined farmlands and oil pipe
burst here in 1970 oil still seeps to the surface.
Nothing is going to grow here. You know, it's, it's, it's,
the land has been devastated by all production in some places.
Surface water contains 900 times the accepted level of which causes
cancer. So Ken's Dad, you know, he was writing articles about this,
he was speaking out about it, but eventually he decided that wasn't enough.
And uh, and I decided,
I think in the late eighties that he was going to take to this
[inaudible]
indigenous people have been cheated [inaudible] laws
in 1993 organized Ogoni Day where 300,000 people came out to protest.
We are going to demand that rights, this swollen one violently.
And we shot with
[inaudible]
over the next month. The protests kept going, they escalated as tension,
increased an oil worker was badly beaten and then shell pulled out of the region
resulting in the closure of oil operations in the area.
And they took millions of dollars with them and the government depended almost
solely on the revenues from that one economic activity. And so
not long after the protests,
Ken's dad was thrown into jail and can junior, he,
he begins frantically traveling the world trying to raise awareness about his
dad's situation to publicly put pressure on,
on general a bash and an IJ is head of state. And on November 10th, 1995,
two years after his dad had been arrested,
Ken is at this international conference,
New Zealand trying to sort of lobby world leaders and he says that after dinner
he just got this funny feeling walking,
walking across one of the streets and I just saw the sunset that evening.
It was a beautiful sunset actually.
Those are those a big Red Sun just sinking into the day.
And um
hm.
I felt something going in my chest
and I think I knew
[inaudible]
I knew then that something had happened. Ken, sorry, we weren't writer.
Human rights activist campaigner on behalf of his fellow tribesmen hang this
morning in a Nigerian prison.
Ken says that world leaders spoke out the prime minister of England,
even Nelson Mandela on, and it was to no avail. Nothing happened,
but it's difficult to know what to do with all of that.
How'd you, how'd you get justice for what? What happened to your father?
Yeah,
you could argue, and this is what lawyers' leader did,
argue that the only way to get justice was, was not to go after the regime,
but to go after Shell and its parent company, Royal Dutch Petroleum.
In going after Shell,
they claimed that they helped the Nigerian government do some horrendous things.
They claimed that shell aided and abetted the Nigerian government and kidnapping
and torture and [inaudible] directly did this stuff or, or aided and embedded.
So the claim is that they would supply guns, that they actually supply guns.
Well actually the allegation, the claim is that a, it's just ammo,
but still that's an, that's not right. That's, and there were other things too,
like they claimed that Shell would call in a dis sort of special forces unit of
the Nigerian government that that colloquially everybody was calling the kill
and go mob. Oh they're claiming shell is calling it hits. Yeah.
Basically that Shell was like, you know,
hand in hand with the government on this. Of course, Sheldon eyes, all this.
And in 2002 people like Ken who had lost brothers,
was family, you know, and also surviving victims of all this violence.
They banded together with some American lawyers and brought a case under the
alien tort statute.
They alleged that Shell was essentially the hostess who Mani Generous the enemy
of,
of the human kind or race and therefore could be tried in American courts.
Yeah. And as you can imagine, they got pushed back in this case,
got challenged all the way up to the supreme court.
We will hear argument first this morning in case 10 1491 he obo versus Royal
Dutch petroleum. Okay. This case was actually argued twice about,
we're combining them here for simplicity.
So the basic issue in this case seemed really simple at first.
Can you use this law against corporations?
Like if you read the Florida decision,
the torture has become like the pirate and slave trader before him.
An enemy of all mankind.
This is justice Kagan actually reading from the Florida decision and saying,
you know, we gave the stamp of approval. The courts have said this is okay.
There were certain categories of offenders, the word today's pirates.
So the question was our corporations in that category,
can they be considered today's pirates?
The principle issue before this court is whether a corporation can ever be held
liable for violating fundamental human rights norms under the alien tort
statute. Okay,
Paul Hoffman, the lawyer representing the Nigerians bringing the case
and and, well, let me start by saying that the,
the international human rights norms that are at the basis of this case,
like all the terrible crimes that we've all already agreed are crimes against
humanity.
All of those using the rights norms are defined by actions.
They're not defined by whether the perpetrator is a human being or a corporation
in a Florida says that tortures are today's pirates.
What about a group of tortures? What about pirates and corporates?
Do you think in the 18th century,
if they brought pirates incorporated and we get all there and gold and the black
beard gets up and he says, oh, it isn't me, it's the corporation.
Do you think that a, they would have then said, oh, it's icy.
It's a cooperation. Goodbye. Go home.
That's justice briar.
Basically agreeing that in this case to differentiate between like a corporation
doing bad things and a person doing bad things, it's, it's kind of silly.
This case clearly struck justice briar powerfully.
The question to me is who are today's pirates? He says,
Adolf Hitler was like a pirate. Hitler is the pirate who is there,
the dread pirates of our, and we have treaties
that say there is universal jurisdiction.
The alien twist Fascia as it was applied to human rights cases from Florida on
is part of a trend in, in the world today.
The trend in the world today is towards universal justice.
For people that and and, and corporations that violate these kinds of norms.
That's the trend. In fact,
the United States has been the leader in that our government has proclaimed our
leadership position.
We thought the argument went extremely well and we really did not see how we
should lose,
but then it was shells turn.
The trouble is that the choice to pursue corporations semi mine again might've
killed the goose that laid the golden eggs because on the one hand it makes
sense to shift to corporations. They have the money. On the other hand,
corporations will use their money to hire the best lawyers they can buy
lawyers like the stolen Kathleen Sullivan,
MR chief justice and may it please the court.
When Kathleen Sullivan got up there,
she in the defense team basically sidestep the whole issue of whether
corporations should or should not be considered pirates.
Whether this law should or should not be applied to corporations,
they actually went bigger.
They started talking about all the reasons why actually using the ATS for
non-American crimes might be a really bad idea for anyone.
It came down to three main points. One reciprocity.
We fear that if we say that a United States court can be open to try any accused
law of nations violator for anywhere in the world,
regardless of the place of the conduct the other nations of the world might see
to do the same to us. Basically,
if we can take people from other countries and try them in our courts,
what's stopping them from doing that to us should inform your decision today and
the second point made by Shell through the offense to the principle against
international friction is that its highest international friction like this
could cause a diplomatic nightmare. You're basically saying other countries,
these judges that you didn't elect, we didn't like them either. Frankly,
I didn't vote for them. You didn't vote for them.
They were appointed and now they're going to be patrolling international law.
Are we really comfortable with that?
And I want to stress that our point is that the u s is projecting here our law
onto foreign countries and finally
and the statement of the case is really striking this case on the most basic
level. What does a case like that?
What business does a case like that have in the courts of the United States?
How is this any of our business, no connection to the United States whatsoever.
It's a point that really jive with Justice Alito.
Why does this case belong in the courts of the United States? Well,
there's nothing to do with the United States other than in fact,
in a way a subsidiary. In that moment,
he sort of captured how America had shifted.
We didn't want to pretend to be that shining city on the hill anymore.
That was over.
I have the opinion for the court and case number 10 1491 Keough bull and others
versus Royal Dutch Petroleum Company and others.
In the end,
the court decided to rule in favor of Shell and Royal Dutch petroleum.
The chief justice wrote the decision
Justice Story wrote in 1822 that no nation has ever yet pretended to be the
customers more. I'm of the whole world,
the guardian of morals of the whole world. First,
it's just a matter of common sense that when Congress passes a law,
it is passing the law that applies in the United States and not some other
country unless the law tells us otherwise. Second,
regulating conduct abroad risks,
serious foreign policy consequences and courts are and should be reluctant to
invite such consequences unless that is what Congress clearly intended and we
see no reason.
He says that extra territorial conduct conduct that's outside the United States
isn't going to count it.
There has to be some relationship to the United States.
Basically they took the ATS and they clipped its wings. Do you feel like the,
I'll tell you the reason that the thought brewing in my mind and I'm wondering
if you would agree or you think it's stupid. Um, the,
the sense that I have with the ATS is that it came about at a moment of great
idealism and hope [inaudible] and now after the fog is cleared, so to speak,
it seems to represent not just hope but naive Tay [inaudible] the fact that we
think we can change the world did it's that easy.
The ATS and Ha, it's falling out of favor somehow represents in a way,
the way in which we fall had a kind of sober awakening. I wonder,
do you feel like human rights
in the way we understood it is dead?
No, it's, I think it's transformed our, our idealism,
but maybe the,
the disaster and Keough ball was a moment of kind of stepping back to think a
bit more broadly about how we can make the world a better place.
And Samuel Moine says we do need to rethink some things. Frankly,
it's a little dishonest to just pretend
that America brings justice to the world.
Air America was founded on the idea of human rights,
which was the first nation in the history of the world to be founded explicitly
on such an idea, which is, is not really true. And,
and as Dave presented their cases,
the human rights movement leaves out how much the United States has often been
involved in the eval they're portraying in court.
So at the very least,
he says that what this decision shows us is that before we run around judging
other countries, we should take a hard look at ourselves. Absolutely.
But more importantly,
in the end, we can avoid the question, what's the Best Bang for our buck?
It's just not proven yet that ATS is it
he all you really had
was a few individuals who won cases. And by the way,
most of them never got any money. Really? Yeah.
Dolly didn't get paid. You know, after she won, Pena fled again.
And so in a way that alien tort statute didn't have far to fall to begin with.
Oh. So they're just symbolic victories.
You could definitely see it that way. Do you feel like you got justice?
Did what? Did you get after this? Yes. Yes. But Dolly,
Florida doesn't, you didn't get any money back, correct?
Yeah. But it never was for, for, for the money. This,
the money won't pay who don't remove backward Leto I fine
that were Leto
no normal [inaudible]
yeah,
I know how to say that they named sometime, but that there was a reason.
Yes, yes. I lost a brother,
but when we won that case,
he in in knew your in United day I get so many other brothers and sisters
through all lover the war that they find
that Lito DVN diet
and don't leave for them.
[inaudible]
pretty serious. Kelsey Padgett and Kelly prime,
so the debate about the ATS and the America's role in the world continues.
The court just heard arguments in another ATS case.
This term it's called Jester v Arab Bank.
It's a suit brought by nearly 6,000 plaintiffs against a Jordan based bank
accused of financing terrorism.
Odds are that the court will use the case to further limit the ATS,
but that remains to be seen
[inaudible].
Okay. More perfect is produced by me jet at boom rod with Susie Lichtenberg,
Julia Long Gloria Kelly prime, Shawn Ramas from Alex Overington and Saraj.
Cari.
This episode was produced with Kelsey paget and significant editing Juju from
Jenny Lawton. Take a Jenny. We also had help from Elie ms style,
Christian Pfarius, Linda Hirshman,
David Gable and Michelle Harris Supreme Court. Audio is from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with the legal information institute at
Cornell.
Leadership support for more perfect is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
Additional funding is provided by the Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation.
Additional music for this episode was by Nicolas Carter,
and I'm a sad note, Ken. Sarah, we were jr who appears in this episode,
passed away in October, 2016.